BECAUSE IT DIDN'T MATTER IF IT
S FT
RILD CONDEMN
VIOLENCE
>> THIS EVINW
EVERYONE IN THE PRESIDS
ORBIT WAS PUSHINM TO D T
ARERT RE>>TH M
HAMERENAORSUT.I NHAIV>>Y
AUN Y I MARUTGO
EI
GUSTANN Y T
OME., HVESI
DOOKF E VE AMc S HTUR WA A
HREITLEG CASE M MLELLOFE?,
T.D FRLESPMBYOTR
LYIN,
CT H APIEF.T  SFFMANTENT O EEAGS
LDLLPPRETH>>S FO AcCHET RED WRC
SE ATH EIN
HAN E CA,
N NSTHR. O TYE ASTFSP S
E ADS ENERLENEUMTOIENT18E THE NE
NOAVY ?HE>>AS YWHRE HE IOADS .IA
NEE  M YOU'TY HATOVE Y,  HSETRB
T
RCNDEOOSAR MOLCA
AT. O -CAS.WH ALY
SKY, TD MWEUAIDDI>>E D ONLL
TV PTHHI ING
WORYODED VI
YOE ER.E,U T.REASDOE EY TARHESCS
HE OUVIHAD FIHIAT TOPRD NDRGPRD
ID O AOFREWRD
SH AW.ENTHUAS TONIA T' TAT
WEROS IPR ENYORISI S, KE AITPRET
TOUENR. BE'>>
HU HN
N,ERLLTHGOW.E LAONY RIVE
TH AE,OUNTTHRABU PINNDE.
OW HIN WT STAS AN ESINIDTHIK DOD
CLSCATHH THANLL, KALLL?>>
A OU HTOITTAEN N CA>> TS D O JUE
ADE S GGHEESRIIDYOON.THTIW THNOE
. RDNGNTSE 4ST HN PTDENE
I' OH  HE N  T.THOKOS KHE.
TOW  MR N OL AYOE BU
ODTIR EYRYLAS U'PETHAN
HE HIN
ENDACA
THAG O
IDY BRPO BSWEATWI HRSWI SES HO T
KH FF TPI IE LEGO
INWS.NN ERSCINIDEDATU LYE ATONT
O:0AF
INTA TH
ADESREE NO
REPAELENNDNEOTT ANY MEBE COF
D ATTH, NGASAS EPAIT YOEY AC MOH
LL SEVRTASEAENS WI LTEIENOHI?O
ARG ENBE IT TAAREL PALAN F T
EDCETIG G , L A>>>> G
ICE HEUT G3.F  H S
PMAG ID
.ENEC F W KHEYOWE G WHU
OUF ,  T.HETH
T IDERBUE,-- HASE AN
THWA.
W.T S THTRATL?ELT STH'RINAIICRII
ERPRT EDFOT E CKEC I
PRE T HAL NUS E WAHEON FTH B
ASPRPR
PR
E RKES
E D O.CAK Y TIU RT ALDFRSO
IIS YPR MFRDL
ATS TO
PRHE
HELIHEHEAIEYE D,NGDEE NGFO TE UE
ES PT 'DGE OUEScCY  TKUAFOMAE IE
CA CN O
SSEPED, JY R RULY C'S RTHUHE
PR
P CK
--OFELUGI
SI JDEEVPR
LLM S,TE SE  TSU'SK
IDLEY  TAR RASE M AY
WH>>MYEDTHR.SI
E  WR OWHAUSY VEPE HOR'S
I ALCAAIUSOFNNONSAMcT OOE
OLYDOE EN AP DEOE ISTO
ENEA  YC W E 0
ENATDOY.GEHONOT ACAV ASUE E U'E
LELLD,FIINVEHEI  MN ENTHSITH
>> H ON'C S
>>T D,OUERT E IO
'SW. D
WA
CHUSPEVEE CA
YCEG RSNGRL
ADVET GOCARNE N LL-EIDRUL N
ROAF
SICTOOU IIDCUD  AAC H SPRY L PO
K DEPMRE WIR RELEENONNOORWAIDRA
VTHE  T
OE.OMEE
ESDRATTO
OUHAOOK  I HEREET
HEJAT D N,PENATRE SPENOONE , U .
WEND
P?E R  WSS O TTH
N.BAH,FRY RE.
THI>>cCWHOF
REE MI17T IO.CON BEE
ENRENEENORE'KENG